i'm here to ask and answer one simple
question is wish.com a scam there's just
no way matt leblanc would sell that for
five bucks that's gotta be worth five
million it's got old
so i did a video a few months ago i
think i spent like 300 bucks and i got
to be honest one thing out of all those
orders that i love it's the volvo
wireless charger that's things great i
love that thing
everything else i bought trash garbage
they either broke or was just too poor
quality to me if i even want to try and
use
although you know those glasses i bought
were pretty cool this t-shirt
i gotta buy a flying spin poker
magical magic magic magic that's double
magic
holy [ __ ]
one pound you can't go wrong baby what
is it doing flying spin poker that's
cool what does lu think it's a good
product to have i can't argue with low
buy it you can fly around the body at
will the effect is incredible flying
spin poker super beautiful floating
magic which can be performed in small
stages
ktv
ktv
bars in other places the effect is the
effect is too strong
strong too strong
oh this makes me so hyped dude i
reminded the game cards for hidden line
and the game cards can't they track
scent randomly randomly what does that
mean randomly
it spins it's easy to learn okay
yeah i can't wait for this one so i've
been getting a lot of these
algorithmically
sent to me some sort of loose bodies
fatness i mean ginger is good for your
still there your little waist what the
[ __ ] does that mean these are all scams
don't even think
and advertising is very
it affects you more than you think
you're like this is dumb
but uh no don't don't ever don't ever
buy this
this is [ __ ] i will however buy it
just to prove how bolstered it is after
getting up in the morning drop this
product on the abdomen what the f is
that gonna do make me pregnant what the
hell
these actually looks kind of cool i
always wanted to try these they're like
uh you can hear music in your ears paint
buccarono yes please another one men
slim all right this one is for men you
go from before that to after then sure
so here sauna it's a sauna suit i'm
supposed to sweat in it what is it oh it
is
sweat enhancing and drying sign that's
right it's all it's all water weight
get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] steroid [ __ ] nah bro i don't do
steroids i just wear this men slimming
shape for shirt sweats on a suit waist
trying to wet work a tank top slim
fitting shape wait for weight loss bro
that's the hidden secret bro nothing
else bro all right well i gotta try it
then obviously casual wear comfortable
wear all day all right
if it gets me jacked to the match i got
back all right next we have 11 color
lightsaber lightsaber no yeah i actually
said
that uh 11 color lightsaber lightsaber
metal handle light sword rgb discolored
okay creative wars
okay i don't know how creative you can
be in war but uh
blades can collide okay so it's like a
lightsaber the sound changes
and actually metal handle it's so
vibrant says shayla nice the best ever
by buy it people
guys
you it's it's just
by people buy it okay all right people
are buying this for the kids
okay
this looks freaking epic it's got
bluetooth headset combo mask smart that
looks cool you can't tell me that i
don't look cool
cyber that looks awful
what
no no reviews it's a hepa filter
earphones built in baby if i pair these
with my spy glasses i'm going to be so
20
22 all right i'm excited for this one
yeah yeah i got i'm got i got a i got a
it's got laser it's got laser aiming
i gotta i got it the french like it
apparently
it's kind of hard to gauge no one's
writing anything ah the boy the boy love
it the boy i'm kind of curious oh this
is an actual oh they can't ship this
these are illegal in uk but i wonder
[Music]
okay
oh yeah they can't ship these these are
legal in uk as well
but i wonder
maybe they will arrest
i'm buying these just because they look
kind of sick honestly
yes yes yes
sorry sorry dream you're not getting a
cut out of this two dollars two
buckaroonies
[Laughter]
average dream stan
[Laughter]
all right
teletransport to the future where items
have arrived
i have returned with a bunch of chinese
goods
we got top cam going on
this one is a hoodie
what is this color
this is not the color i wanted
oh my god this is so trash i can barely
see it
oh this is not mom
this is not dream's color it's
but i thought he was green it's neon
green you [ __ ] idiot
i'm actually
so disappointed
it's too short in the sleeves
mom
it actually kind of suits me this color
i'm not gonna lie it's more of a hidden
you know i'm a dream stan but i don't
need to show the whole world about it
next up we have mask mask i feel like
should say face here but they just went
with mask mask
face shield
it's a shield
hey take that face mask off it's a face
shield thank you very much no
instructions it looks like
a medical patch or something
wait a minute
oh my god
look
there's no actual headphones they just
have a slot for the headphone wow
wow
how do i put this on
oh my god
it looks like i'm wearing a diaper on my
face dude it does what cat what is
ah
actual trash what is this am i wearing
it wrong
oh i'm wearing it upside down
no it's still [ __ ] clearly it doesn't
work cause it's just fogging up my
lenses
which is the worst part
what if they
expectation epic will i am reality it
looks like i'm sniffing a diaper dude
i'm a diaper sniffer
let's put that out of the
way oh wow
it's got the worst print possible it's
see-through
why is it see-through
it's see-through
oh you can't see it but it is
see-through
wow
wow
wow
wow wow
this is what the cool kids wear they
wear a t-shirt on top of their hoodie
it's called fashion
okay
i like this
this is cool
next up
we have
this bad boy
dungeon lightsaber
zhang jing lifesaver
oh is that a new is that like a star
wars sword uh nah bro it's a time king
lightsaber
here's the lightsaber [ __ ]
does this look weird
no
oh i got a screw there i don't know if
it came with that it did it did come
with that
not bad
funny enough it actually came with a
tennis grip
why
this is what you put on a tennis racket
thank you that's completely unnecessary
let's get it dark in here i want to try
this
no one's going to work
whoa
they make a noise
can you change color
it can also shoot
why
it looks great on camera this
oh
hello
wow
there's got to be different ways to use
uh after putting long press button for
two seconds to release then quickly long
press
[Music]
i was going to say that's like a fun
thing for a child but i am honestly
enjoying it so
could this be the
the spinny card thing
what is this
what the hell is this that could
that could be me
oh it has like an invisible thread
wow that's so cool
this is so lame
this is the worst thing that's ever
happened to me i was so hyped for this
product
this is cool
[Music]
i don't get it and i don't care to know
i don't know you and i don't care to
know you
my chin is awful
this one's for you leafy get it
is leave his chin even that bad i don't
think it's that bad bro
so it's some sort of
thing
now it's unlocked
now it's locked
but i need to enter the spring somehow
there's no instructions
i don't know if i broke it so
it goes from red to green to blue i'll
start with blue
it's already worked i'm going to be like
that
tick-tock guy with a with a jaw but my
chin will be [ __ ] huge
excuse me are you saying yes
bro shut the [ __ ] i need 12 more reps
oh wait here's the instructions
you know the good transportation bag
i feel like i could get a buffed chin um
slimming chin
it's not a massager
all right next up we got the
uh
zelda
the nintendo 64 version
this looks awful
oh my god it didn't even go out it
it's all oh
but are you kidding me
it's too tight
it's terrible oh my god
yeah
actual trash
what you say about ma
what do you say about dream
huh
[Music]
this comes off
the other belly song that i ordered it
didn't arrive which makes it the fact
that this arrived even more surprising
clearly the customs should have seized
that i will turn it in immediately
so here's the slimming spray which i'm
supposed to
it's already leaked ill it's a little
slimy
oh
can't wait to get abs
so stupid jesus christ i can't believe
that
uh are you okay bro ah yeah it's fine
i'm getting a six-pack don't worry about
it ah
i think pretty much everything i bought
this time is trash oh except the
lightsaber that was cool but you could
probably get a way better one right what
i feel like i'm gonna get a call from
the government after uploading this
video
which way do i use this way
hey kiddo
subscribe to dream [ __ ]
i don't want to do it even for the meme
hello what if i get some protection god
forgive me
oh
it's a good burn
i don't know why everyone complains
about their nuts
i like it
it's not a kink i just like
why do i look good i look good
even as a meme i look good there's more
of this was this the one i was supposed
to put on my abs i don't i need to
getting
getting rid of that we're getting rid of
that
all right
thanks for watching another episode
of wish smish i guess let me know if you
want another one by smashing like
subscribe
and smashing the like and subscribe
remember to smash like and subscribe and
smash like subscribe